[Music]
let's talk about kf a new tool that lets
you quickly modernize your cloud foundry
workloads and use the same cloud foundry
concepts you know and love but on
kubernetes if you're a platform owner
using cloud foundry you're not going to
want to miss this video
cloud foundry's easy to use developer
workflow allowed application teams to
almost magically deploy code to an
application infrastructure they knew
nothing about and in just a couple of
minutes using a few terminal commands
but over time cloud foundry as a
platform has become legacy
applications evolved microservices
exploded customers moved to the cloud
using kubernetes as their container
orchestrator
but many of these customers wanted a
familiar intuitive developer abstraction
on top of kubernetes so how could you
move to kubernetes and maintain that
same developer experience
that's where kf comes into play
kf provides a smooth stepping stone from
what you had before to what's next it
allows you to modernize workloads by
running them on gke and athos but what
makes kf special is that it minimizes
developer downtime by allowing
developers to retain the same cloud
foundry workflow they already use
so just like in cloud foundry when you
typically type the cf push command to
build and deploy your code you can do
the same with kf by saying kf push
so same workflow but now instead of
operating three to four updates behind
because of complex tooling you can use
up-to-date tooling and dependencies you
get the advantages of integrating new
updates quickly and once you're on the
cloud it becomes a lot simpler to try
different managed or unmanaged products
you see at its core kf is an abstraction
layer that makes it easier for
applications to run on kubernetes gke or
even athos kf becomes your bridge to the
cloud providing an easy process for
modernizing workloads
not only that once you're using google
cloud billing becomes straightforward
and cost gets significantly reduced
because google cloud understands modern
workloads
instead of paying commercial licensing
fees your organization can just now run
kubernetes instead of maintaining a
pivotal cloud foundry environment in a
cloud architecture with kf you can save
cost by running everything on a single
platform
but don't take my word for it be sure to
watch corelogic's cloud solution
architect jeff henry's google next talk
which details their transition to the
cloud using kf
in it you'll see how corelogic
re-platformed ten thousand plus cloud
boundary applications using kf you learn
how this tooling minimize developer
disruption by retaining the cloud
foundry experience
while also standardizing platform
automation on kubernetes
annual review the assessment and
migration tools corelogic used to
automate and accelerate their migration
to kubernetes
wrap up i want to point out three use
cases that make kf an excellent tool for
platform admins to quickly modernize
their infrastructure using kubernetes
one
to help you develop a migration plan you
can use the kf command line tool to
assess your current cloud foundry
environment and create an inventory of
all the cloud foundry resources
two
you can also use kf as a drop-in
replacement for the cloud foundry cli to
keep the same developer workflow as
before just swap cf push for kf push and
you should be good to go
and finally at runtime kf can be used to
provide an abstraction layer over cloud
foundry so that cloud foundry
applications can run on kubernetes
unchanged
so this is my call to action for any
cloud foundry customer if you're running
an open source or any commercial version
of cloud foundry try kf
it's a bridge to getting your
application running on modern tooling
like kubernetes and gke which is the
number one managed kubernetes
distribution
so to get started check out the
documentation listed below
the getting started guide is especially
lovely if you want to explore the tool
for yourself
and you can always reach out to the
project stakeholders whose emails are
listed in the description below that's
all for now see you next time
[Music]
you